yeah i mean something else that might be
interesting
uh are you know so i've read a lot about
uh about men in particular you know
why we are driven to do these things
that that uh that we do
and something like like weightlifting or
playing sports things like this um
well one reason why for example men want
a weight lift is to to build big muscles
and the research does show on research
on attraction that women are more
attracted to to men with big muscles uh
muscular men
are uh they report having more sexual
partners relative to less muscular men
um part of this is because uh you know
building muscles is costly
right it's a sort of fitness indicator
not in this
not fitness in the sense of like you
know sporty or athletic but but fitness
in terms of
uh reproductive fitness darwinian
fitness
if you can build muscles it indicates a
lot of things about you
uh it indicates that you're able to
obtain you know calories the resources
necessary to build those muscles
uh it indicates conscientiousness which
is a personality trait
someone who can who regularly goes to
the gym that person is diligent and
hard-working
they have goals and stick to them um
and then of course you know they confer
uh protective
advantages too you know people are less
likely to mess with a with a muscular
guy
relative to a smaller guy yeah um and so
yeah you see some of this uh
in in the research um yeah muscular men
report uh more sexual
sexual partners i just want to kind of
dig
into that for a second here um
the fact that women find those traits
attractive
and a man has those traits suggests that
if she was to mate with him
that her children would have those
traits which means that they are more
likely
to reproduce because other women will
find that to be attractive
uh yeah yeah so this is uh some some
call this the the sexy sun hypothesis
um which is a brilliant name yeah yeah
so
so this is uh i first learned about this
i think in matt ridley's book the red
queen this uh the sexy sun hypothesis is
basically this idea that
women are attracted to men who are
attractive to
other women and the reason is because if
they have sons with this man
that their sons will also be attractive
to lots of women and thereby
you know uh pass on those genes but yeah
i mean the basic idea
you're describing is that yeah when
women want uh
men who have certain qualities because
you know those qualities will tend to
pass down to their offspring
um but i think it's also important to
make clear that these aren't um
you know these aren't calculated or sort
of
uh you know deliberate uh you know
strategies that we're enacting
a lot of this is going on sort of under
the hood um we're not even aware
of why we like what we like or why we do
what we do we just know that it makes us
feel good
um you know so you know what when a
woman likes a muscular man it's not
because you know all of these operations
are going on well if
all my kids will be muscular and their
kids will be muscular if there's a woman
out there
who's gone through her gone through that
discourse that we've just had
in her mind i want to meet her and talk
to her because she'd be fascinating
but um yeah you're totally correct and
that was the point i really wanted to
to try and get out of you can you
explain how
genes and what they do to promote
genetic fitness
and emotions and feelings and the more
conscious side of the brain how those
two things interlink i think
um is it robert wright that says
uh genes are the preferences and
emotions that are executed
something like that yeah yeah i mean
genes are basically selected for
and basically through evolutionary
pressures
uh shape certain behaviors um and of
course like there are other factors
involved cultural factors social factors
and so on but
you know a lot of our behaviors are our
strategies
um enacted through our genes and it's
not like we're consciously aware of it
we're just sort of going through these
motions in the same way that say
you know when you're when you're eating
sugar
you're not going through this calculated
process of you know well i'm eating the
sugar because it's giving me caloric
energy which
i can expend later and so on um the
sugar just makes us feel good and our
genes give us this little reward
you know our biology gives us this
little being like okay you're eating
sugar it makes you feel good because
that's advantageous
um but things don't make you feel good
for no reason
right like everything that makes you
feel good is something that at least in
the ancestral environment
you know paid off um in an evolutionary
sense
um so when you when you see a beautiful
woman or you see a
particularly you know athletic man or
whatever it happens to be you feel a
little bit good
you know you feel some positive uh
response to that
and none of this is deliberate or
calculated it's it's just sort of you
know built right into us and
you know it's it's yeah it's not it's
not anything that um
that we're really thinking about
necessarily
[Music]